while I was in the UK this was was this
coincidence I'm not sure if this was
coincidence I get attacked by one of the
lean leading limeys
who is now always poking his nose into
American politics that of course would
be John Oliver John Oliver went after me
personally on the issue of transiting
the kids
I've been fueled by
acknowledge about what gender affirming
care actually consists of summed up by
comments like this if a child walked
into a doctor's office and said doc I
want you to cut my fingers off the doc
would say you've got some problems kid
we need to refer you to a psychiatrist
if the same child walks into that
doctor's office and says doc I want you
to cut my uterus out the doctor would
say that doctor would say oh well you're
a wonderful Brave person you're so right
we do need to cut your uterus out as
soon as possible let's get this young
lady over to the operating room what are
you talking about absolutely every bit
of that is unrealistic from the fact
that no one in this country has ever
been able to have one conversation with
a doctor without first discussing
Insurance to the notion of a young child
using the term doc why is the fictional
child in this [ __ ] scenario using
the same vocabulary as a chaotic rabbit
from the 1940s none of this makes any
sense none of this makes any sense there
isn't it ha ha ha so his answer to my
objection to the
doctors transfing the kids his objection
or his reaction to that is to make a
joke about how we should have socialist
Health Care
and to make a joke about Bugs Bunny
and frankly
those are the strongest arguments he had
against what I said now he he went on
and tried to muster something resembling
a coherent argument so what's my
position my position is that Health Care
institutions at the encouragement of the
culture and the state by the way going
all the way up to Joe Biden all the way
up to the federal government are
encouraging little kids
to undergo gender transition which
involves bodily mutilations it involves
the injection of chemicals popping of
pills to castrate themselves often to
sterilize themselves to make them look
more like the opposite sex that's my
argument I'm saying that's bad and John
Oliver said what that's not really
happening
to hear some tell it as soon as a child
declares themselves trans there was an
immediate irreversible surgical decision
undertaken and there just isn't so let's
break down exactly what gender affirming
care consists of because in younger
children it can mean nothing more than a
social transition like calling them by a
new name or giving them a new haircut or
clothing or providing them with
psychological or behavioral supports
because to be very clear prepubescent
children are not eligible for medical
interventions now at the onset of
puberty and Adolescent and their family
might consider puberty blockers hormones
that delay puberty there we go oh wait
oh you just kind of there you just kind
of undermined his whole argument
because he said no this is not happening
this is not happening
my British accent has not improved while
I've been in the UK so I'll just go back
to do my I'll I'll go back to every
British accent just being Paul McCartney
John Oliver says you know this isn't
happening actually you know this isn't
happening it's not no no children are
being trans or anything okay no uh no
prepubescent children are going on
puberty blockers until they hit puberty
then they go on the puberty bloggers
yeah talk to John and George and Ringo
about that
the obviously
children who are not about to hit
puberty don't need to go on the puberty
blockers in order to block puberty
because they're not going through
puberty
but little children
who are about to begin puberty are being
put on these puberty blockers and it's
not just a fringe case and it's not just
one weird story here or there this is
being pushed to Nationwide and it's
being pushed by the federal government
and it's being pushed by the very
confused mentally ill man Dr Richard
Levine who thinks that he's a woman and
who is pushing his own sexual Hang-Ups
on poor little kids and he's encouraging
them to take puberty blockers and to
take cross-sex hormones and to have
gender mutilation surgeries all of which
fall under the umbrella of gender
affirming care according to these
absolute Ghouls and these child abusers
in these perverts that is all happening
and John Oliver is making the argument
as the left always does this isn't
happening and it's good that it is
that's why this isn't happening and it's
really really good we're not rigging the
election and it's so good that we rigged
the election
if you say we rigged the election you're
an insurrectionist terrorist here is a 3
000 word Time magazine article telling
you how we rate the election
we're not transiting the kit we nobody
is pushing for abortion on demand for
that apology and it's good that we have
the right to abortion up until the very
moment of birth
nobody's transiting the kids and kids
need this gender affirming care well
this doesn't affect little This only
affects older kids but we have to put
them on puberty blockers 25 year olds
don't go through puberty guys
and they claim the libs claim that these
drugs are reversible they're totally
reversible they're simply not you know
go watch Matt's movie the one thing I
missed when I was out of the country
that I really wanted to attend I was
supposed to speak at Matt's rally to
stop transiting the kids it was a huge
success I was looking at the the photos
and the videos a huge huge success why
because the people are obviously on our
side of this issue the reason I bring up
John Oliver is
is not even to you know just kind of get
into a urinating contest with this limey
who's got a nose for American politics
the reason I bring it up is
foreign if you heard my argument which
is hey it's kind of bad that children
are allowed to go to Doc and encourage
to go to doctors right now and mutilate
their bodies and then you heard his
argument which is that's come on that's
not real what does he sound like books
bunny hot come on no they're just
getting gender affirm and care and
they're being told that they're actually
the boys are little girls and then
they're being put on puberty bloggers
come on man if you just heard those two
arguments which one do you think is the
normal argument which which guy there do
you think is the crazy radical guy and
which guy do you think is the normal
Common Sense guy I don't mean to toot my
own horn but I think any unless you are
a radical leftist
even if you don't like me personally
even if you don't care about the
transgender issue you hear those two
arguments the argument that we are
making is obviously the common sense
normal argument that everyone has
believed throughout all of human history
until five minutes ago
and the radical crazy Fringe argument is
the John Oliver argument it's not even
much of an argument at all
and even you know even to John Oliver's
point when he says and they're not all
going on drugs some of them are just
being told that they're actually the
opposite sex as if that doesn't matter
as if the physical world is all that
matters and all that matters is putting
chemicals into your body no of course
not
if a little of a little kid a little boy
is told every day starting in
kindergarten that he's actually a little
girl and there is a a kind of social
currency that goes along with
identifying as transgender and it's
being pushed by the president of the
United States
don't you think that's either going to
deepen his sexual confusion if he has
some already or it's just going to plant
it there in the first place don't you
think that the social metaphysical
aspect of Our Lives matters too I think
it does in many ways I think it matters
a lot more than the physical aspect of
Our Lives of course that that's child
abuse too and it's so amazing it's so
incredible that the libs on the one hand
are are so belligerently opposed to
so-called homosexual conversion therapy
you know where a gay guy shows up to a
psychiatrist and says or psychologist
and says hey Doc I have the same-sex
attraction and I don't really want to
and I don't want to live a homosexual
lifestyle so but I don't know what to do
about it and then the doctor says well
here are some tools you know to kind of
try to deal with those desires that you
don't want to have that is that's the
worst thing ever that has to be banned
to people who the doctors who practice
that need to be thrown in prison that's
gay conversion there that's so awful
but the libs are actively encouraging
transgender conversion therapy on the
other side two little kids the kind of
conversion therapy that says little kid
goes up and says you know you know a dog
I I think I'm a girl this week and then
this Predator doctor says oh yeah you
are you are a girl stop don't even call
yourself Johnny anymore you're Sally and
all your teachers are gonna have to call
you Sally and pretty soon we're going to
get you on those puberty blockers that
by the way are going to make a ton of
money for big Pharma and yeah then we're
going to get you into the gender
mutilation surgeries and oh yeah that
that is both of those Therapies
are operating on the idea that talking
things out and forming one's psychology
and spiritual views on this matter of
your metaphysical self of your soul is
going to affect your life and your
identity
and John Oliver is saying oh no it's not
a big deal when it's being done
pro-trans it's the worst thing in the
world when it's the gay conversion
therapy and it's it's it's threatening
people's lives and it's going to cause
them all to commit suicide but oh when
it's with the little kids that you're
convincing them they're the opposite sex
oh it doesn't even matter it's nothing
that's nothing it's no big deal
and by the way it's not happening and
it's good that it is now you know it's
music Monday I'm so very glad to be here
for music Monday the producers have
chosen
so I don't know anything about this song
or this musician but I'm going to give
you my absolute
highest most sophisticated pop cultural
analysis you know I'm Wonder Mike and
I've come to say hello I'm I'm a rap
Mogul A hip-hop Maven I'm just a culture
vulture baby the rest of the show is
continuing now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]